for the first time ever facebook removed
one of the president's posts twitter
doing the same
both saying the president's message
breaks their rules against spreading
misinformation about coronavirus
joining in joining us now at the white
house is counsel to the president
kellyanne conway kellyanne good morning
to you thanks for being here
and of course there is a debate
happening whether or not facebook and
twitter
should be arbiters of truth and decide
what is fact and fiction
we can have that talk in just a moment
but i want to put up the latest cdc
numbers on coronavirus cases
in children under the age of 18.
under 18 accounts for about 7.4 percent
of confirmed
cases that is up 6.7
from two weeks ago and up nearly six
percent from a month ago
so kids are getting this disease
kellyanne
yes they are and thankfully most never
make it to a hospital and and very few
have
died every death is a tragedy every
single one let me make very clear
uh but those are national numbers and
not every state or
even county or school district is the
same that's why you see so many of these
parents overwhelmingly when they're
surveyed
sandra say do you feel like it's safe to
send your son or daughter back to school
and
many of these parents are saying yes
please do that and they're being big
footed by one
health commissioner in a county or a
school board or a few in the teachers
union and i think we have to take into
account
what everybody is saying here i'm also
happy to report that based on the code
report i received here this morning at
the white house
the overall test positivity rate has
declined eight percent since last week
and zero states
have seen an increase overall since
tuesday so as dr burks and others have
been saying
we are we're seeing a flattening
governor ducey was here yesterday from
arizona showing a great model
i think for the country they had a huge
surge in june
i want to stick to children though
because the debate right now is over the
spread of misinformation by the
president
about children being nearly immune
having under 18 uh kids in this country
get the disease 7.4 percent of the time
is not nearly immune
and you you want to dial down to
specific states and
and districts where schools are
reopening what's happening with children
i spoke to the governor of mississippi
last night and he said
the kids are spreading it listen
what's happened is that many of these
kids when they started back school early
last week
came into the schools they came in and
they had the virus
we actually have a hundred students
approximately that are quarantined now
you know those who want to attack
everyone look at that as a negative i
actually look at it as a positive
the system is working whereby we've
identified positive cases we've contact
traced
those back and we're trying to protect
those kids so is it helpful for the
president
to tell parents that children are nearly
immune from this
and then have it factually spreading
child to child in places like
mississippi where they've opened the
doors to their schools well many
interviews the president makes very
clear uses the new jersey example
information he got from governor phil
murphy a democrat of new jersey
that in new jersey which was i think the
second hardest hit state for a while
uh you had i'm told one child under the
age of 18 who passed away and that
individual had underlying conditions
that's the information i have so i think
the president is making clear
uh that overall the average age of those
who pass from chronovirus is still at
about 78
over 40 percent of those who have passed
away were in long-term facilities or
nursing homes i learned that in the
coronavirus task force meeting in the
oval office
two short days ago sandra we had the
task force meeting in there i was there
for the entire thing i listened to dr
fauci dr redfield dr burks
you know these are the facts and figures
but i think the we also
have to make very clear that we you know
shut down
a lockdown and shutdown may work for joe
biden in wilmington it doesn't work for
the rest of the country and doesn't work
for many of our school children
we can't create a pandemic within a
pandemic we know from many of the health
professionals
that extended lockdowns and not being in
school and pretending that we can
replicate that online
but the uh increasingly so many other
maladies for these children
and i get that kellyanne and that's
another conversation but the point is
the president in that interview on fox
and friends yesterday morning
said it's going to go away like things
go away
and that is something many people are
taking issue with particularly because
his own health experts at the white
house dr fauci dr burks and others
this is fauci's words i do not believe
it will disappear
because it's such a highly transmissible
virus
so is the president listening to the
advice of the health experts that he has
at his side
he is and they should be listening to
him as well uh we don't
like to hear the first things on tv when
we have coronavirus task force meetings
in the situation room a classified
setting
for an hour and a half and don't hear
certain things there where we can
pressure test them and learn
as a task force and then hear them for
the first time on tv that's not specific
to any one individual
it merely means that the country
benefits when we understand the facts
and figures
here at the white house and they're
brought up to the president and the vice
president
as should be the case but let me let me
make this point you know when twitter
has of all people i'd imagine tens of
thousands of people work at twitter
sandra
when you have somebody who worked for
kamala harris come out and announce
that you're banning the president's
tweet you're taking it down
that itself shows a political motivation
and i think what many of these tech
companies are doing now to the president
to conservatives
the shadow banning the censoring the
selective
engagement is election interference we
got
three were three years worth of election
security election security
now we're gonna do mainland balloting
we're gonna we're going to
shut down the president's twitter feed
at times team trump
got shut down yet the ayatollah khomeini
is up
the w.h.o which told everybody in
january
no evidence of human to human
transmission of covet 19
is still up on twitter uh you've got i
have a whole list of tweets that are
here so sure the biggest lie the biggest
live the last 10 years said by joe biden
you can keep your plan keep your doctor
that's probably going to tweet something
so let me clarify the white house stance
on what you're exactly you're saying but
first i'll point i'll pull up the
facebook post
spokesperson on removing that video
involving the president this video
includes false claims that a group of
people is immune from covid19
which is a violation of our policies
around harmful coveted misinformation
kellyanne you seem to be pointing out
misinformation spread by other people
by other world leaders etc are you
suggesting that there
is a space for facebook and twitter to
monitor and in some cases delete uh
information that is spread
like the president's or whoever else
that you're going to name
right now or should they not be doing it
at all what is the white house stance
well i think look i think they have to
make up their mind the president signed
an executive order about the tech
companies why do we have the tech
overlords telling us what is it is not
legitimate on
on health matters and they immediately
take action against some people and
never others
that's selective engagement if this
really is if this really is the first
amendment they always
hide behind the first amendment then
that should be but remember the
president signed an executive order that
has teeth just this week or last week
the department of commerce sent over to
the sec um some additional
information that we want more
transparency why are pro-life videos
taken down on twitter excluded from
facebook why are
are certain people who defend the second
amendment if you don't like the second
amendment
tell congress to do away with it get get
a different amendment in other words
it's selective engagement twitter
facebook many of these forums are
already
overly overly anti-trump i think what's
happened is
that the president has over 200 million
followers on all the social media
platforms
he has used it the way no other
politician has ever used it or
officially has ever used it
and and they don't and they don't like
that they don't like the fact that
he can use their platforms as a way to
reach americans in a way that well that
can be debated but
i want to move on to the coronavirus
relief package because as a result of
everything we're talking about the
pandemic
there are so many americans who are
still struggling for this so many small
businesses that are still trying to stay
afloat if they survived
uh what we've gone through so far is
mark meadows
angling or pushing the president into
executive action on this it seems like
congress is getting nowhere
well i think pelosi and schumer are
pushing the president toward executive
action because he will not stand
by while americans suffer economically
he has taken
such robust action through the cares act
trillions of dollars in relief
to the states to all combined to the
states
also to the hospitals and reimbursement
over 150 billion dollars i think in
counting
and of course to our small businesses we
kept many small businesses
afloat not just surviving but thriving
they can cover their payrolls
and and now we have last friday the
democrats staying in the way of a
one-week extension of that six hundred
dollars why was last week important
because it was july 31st sandra and
whereas we are concerned about people
who are paying their bills in august
september october pelosi and schumer
only care about how you're going to vote
in november where
is the world where exactly is the
president willing to act alone on this
executive action where
where is he willing to to do that well
he can suspend the payroll
in other words he there are things that
he can do and he's been working with his
economic
team and his lawyers here i know that is
fact to see if he can stand up and stand
in
where congress fails to act there's a
reason congress has about 13
approval rating because people see that
when they bother to show up for work
they don't get anything done
and it seems so partisan leader
mcconnell's been out there doing this
you have
tim scott of south carolina and lamar
alexander of tennessee with a great
school choice now
bill that would help these students who
rely upon
scholarships and opportunity and freedom
to stay in their schools let the money
follow the child if your school's not
going to open up on time and you can
find a school that is
let the money follow the child that
money's there not for the government
it's there for the student
all right so there are many times we
want them to pass but they seem
they seem hell-bent on making this a
partisan exercise and not for the people
who are economically
suffering one other quick question new
gallup survey on economic recovery
are you satisfied or dissatisfied with
the way things are going in the united
states at this time they're only 13
percent
said that they're satisfied your
reaction to that killian that doesn't
surprise me at all 13
is about the approval rating for
congress but that doesn't surprise me at
all we're in the middle of a global
pandemic dual medical and financial
crisis social unrest
that doesn't surprise you the other
gallup number this week that really
caught my eye and it was the new york
times editorial over running out of time
make it quick
is that nine and ten americans don't
want to defund the police including over
eight and ten african-americans and
hispanics
so joe biden's wrong on that he wants to
redirect bill de blasio cut the budget
by one billion dollars and look what's
happening to our cherished new york city
all right we'll have you back soon
kellyanne conway thank you thank you
sandra all right